bonsoir jean jacques hazan bros qui
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france on l'a vu c'est la course au
vaccin la surenchère aujourd'hui moderna
qui annonce également avoir 95 5 % de
réussite après donc spoutnik vph either
11 au stade avancé en phase iii pour le
médecin vous a fait en même temps
professeur d'économie de la santé c'est
plutôt de bonnes nouvelles
oui c'est dans l'ensemble une bonne
nouvelle ça prouve que les différentes
équipes qui sont mis en quête de vax a
progressé évidemment et qu'on n'a pas
été obligé d'interrompre les essais cela
étant dit il s'agit de résultats
extraordinairement préliminaire et il
s'agit dans le meilleur des cas d'une de
la moitié d'une phase iii c'est à dire
qu'on est encore loin
n'en déplaise aux actionnaires à ceux
qui ont déjà vendu des actions pour
s'enrichir très vite on est encore très
loin de la mise à disposition effective
comme votre collaboratrice vient de dire
excellemment alors on se demande en vue
de l'extérieur quand on ne connaît pas à
grand chose dans les détails en tout cas
pourquoi ces annonces à quelques jours
d'écart on a le sentiment ville loin que
c'est une forme de surenchère puisqu'on
effet comme vous le soulignez l'action
suis souvent c'est une surenchère
boursières ces firmes sont des firmes
qui se doivent à leurs investisseurs qui
ces récentes années ou même avec le
début du coc vides ont forcément vu un
fléchissement de leurs activités et de
leurs ventes par le ralentissement de la
consommation de santé un peu partout
dans le monde de la fréquentation des
hôpitaux un peu partout dans le monde et
n'ayant rien à proposer dans le coffee
directement il leur faut combler alors
puisqu'ils ont encore besoin d'être
financés par leurs actionnaires nombreux
par les fonds de pension américains qui
en possèdent de larges parts et qui
demandent une rentabilité à deux
chiffres alors que l'économie croît
péniblement 2 1 et demi ou deux pour
cent les années où ça va bien eh bien il
faut faire ce genre de promesses ce
genre de communication et de communiqués
de presse qui laisse les sceptiques un
petit peu dans l'expectative
pour l'instant on regarde ça avec
beaucoup d'intérêt ça prouve une chose
ça prouve que l'intérêt théorique et
d'un vaccin
modification d'un arn c'est ce que veut
dire modern art qui ne veut pas dire
modernité mais modified arenal
c'est-à-dire l'acide ribonucléique
modifier ça veut dire que la piste
d'utiliser pour la première fois chez
l'humain ce type de vaccin en modifiant
la rn peut se révéler actifs maintenant
combien de temps va durer l'immunité
conférée on ne sait pas y at il des
effets secondaires à long terme
évidemment on ne sait pas on peut on
doit espérer que non et que dans la demi
douzaine de vaccins comme vous le disiez
très justement qui qui s'annonce
1 2 3 5 se révéleront susceptibles
d'être proposés avec des modalités de
logistique d'une part et
d'administration d'autre part et
d'acquisitions pour une troisième par
qui le rendront compatible avec
l'ensemble de la population de la
planète voilà le défi
vous évoquez justement ces techniques n
comme vous dites c'est modern and his
father c'est pas la même technique chez
les russes et des chinois
est ce qu'on est capable aujourd'hui de
mesurer effectivement l'efficacité des
uns et des autres et de comparer au plus
près alors pas encore votre question est
évidemment judicieuse les premiers à
annoncer parce que disposant d'une
technologie assez révolutionnaire mais
qui partait de d'éléments technologiques
connus sont évidemment les deux
laboratoires pfizer et modern a alors
c'est pat frazer en fait c'est pas
yohann tech à leurs associés allemands
qui met en place qui utilisent cette
stratégie qui vise à modifier la rn
c'est un peu compliqué à expliquer ça
vise à transformer le code génétique
donc que que constitue la rn les autres
utilisent des deux ou trois méthodes
différentes
plus classique à partir de virus
existants à paris partir de virus
neutralisent au tués sami un tout petit
peu plus de temps à démarrer mais c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui voyant la
surenchère médiatique
sanofi et glaxo qui sont associés le
français sanofi et le britannique
glaxosmithkline ont annoncé que
ici le printemps ils seraient en mesure
est bien aussi de lancer la production
si les premiers essais s'avérer
favorable avec beaucoup plus de prudence
mais il faut dire que les normes de la
communication et y compris la
communication financière et boursière
sont pas forcément les mêmes de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique est chez nous et
que de ce point de vue là l'angleterre
break site ou pas est encore européenne
ça veut dire clairement qu aujourd'hui
on se bat sur des communiqués de presse
mais ya quand même quelques petites
vérification pourquoi autant de
confiance sinon parce que même la msa
lui de nouvelles encourageantes
il ya des chiffres qui sont extrêmement
positifs vous n'avez pas totalement
confiance vous le le médecin alors j'ai
totalement confiance dans l'idée qu'une
des voies va aboutir
j'ai une assez raisonnable confiance que
l'une des voies proposées par pfizer et
ou par moderna permettra effectivement
de proposer un vaccin
j'ai également confiance que l'une des
autres voies entre guillemets plus
conventionnel permettront d'aboutir à un
vaccin disponible avant l'été prochain
et commercialisable diffusable etc
maintenant vous avez entendu comme moi
de ce qu'a dit votre collaboratrice
votre collègue il ya un instant les
difficultés logistiques les véhicules t
d'administration les difficultés de
conservation la difficulté de mise
effective à disposition pour deux 2
vaccins à quinze jours d'intervalle sont
encore à régler
maintenant nos amis anglo-saxons 10 ou
en dérision louise déry the way s'il ya
une véritable volonté et on ne peut pas
douter qu'il y en ait on trouvera le
moyen de résoudre ces problèmes j'ai
confiance du fait que six ou sept ou
huit des équipes les plus qualifiés au
monde pour aboutir aboutiront forcément
est-ce qu'elles aboutiront toutes les 8
ou pas ou 6 ou 5 ou seulement une
ce qui compte c'est que d'ici l'été
prochain au moins un de ces vaccins est
abouti le reste ça s'appelle pardonner
voilà la rudesse du pression un petit
peu de l'enfumage médiatique mais il en
faut lorsqu'on a besoin de la confiance
des actionnaires des investisseurs
le gouvernement américain
ami des milliards de dollars à la
disposition de ces firmes et avant que
ce gouvernement ne cède la place
il était important de l'en remercier je
pense qu'il faut voir là la wii
pardonnez moi c'est milliards comme vous
dites est ce que ce sont eux qui ont
permis de trouver finalement un éventuel
vaccin aussi vite parce qu'il ya des
maladies qui n'ont jamais trouvé de
vaccins on dit toujours qu'il faut des
dizaines d'années ce sont ces milliards
là finalement il faut remercier
aujourd'hui absolument
il faut remercier 7,6 milliards là et si
l'administration de monsieur trompe
n'avait pas donné deux milliards et demi
à l'une de ces firmes par exemple eh
bien on n'en serait pas là quand on
entendait les chiffres énoncés par votre
collègue tout à l'heure on voit que
l'europe est bien plus comment dirais-je
soucieuse de ses équilibres budgétaires
à des moyens qui sont pas du tout dans
la proportion des de ce qu'est
l'économie américaine et que ici alors
il en est de même de l'économie chinoise
sur laquelle on connaît moins de choses
mais qui sait investir massivement et il
est clair que les milliards veulent dire
des dizaines de chercheurs veut dire des
des dizaines de lots veut dire des
moyens considérables
c'est une question de moyens c'est comme
dans une guerre de les dire
conventionnelle pardonnez-moi l'horreur
mais une guerre armée quand vous avez de
quoi fabriquer plus d'avion plus d'armes
plus de d'entraîner plus de soldats vous
avez plus je sens de gagner la guerre
oui c'est vrai ma dernière question
quand vous voyez les français aussi
méfiant à la limite certaines fois de
coup de théorie un petit peu saugrenue
vous vous l'expliquez comment cette
méfiance de la part de nos compatriotes
alors ça c'est une spécificité française
parce que quand on regarde les taux de
vaccination de couverture vaccinale chez
nos voisins européens
on voit qu'ils sont très nettement
supérieurs aux autres en dehors des
vaccins obligatoires
maintenant il ya une rumeur qui a enflé
sur la mauvaise tolérance des vaccins
sur des incidents ou accidents quelques
accidents probablement dû à des
excipients comme de l'aluminium et
autres qui ne sont plus en cause il y en
a par exemple ni dans le vaccin de
pfizer ni dans celui de modern a pas
plus dans celui de gsk ou d autres d
autres recherches actuellement en cours
mais on a créé des antilles vac et les
sites aujourd'hui avec les réseaux
sociaux les sites de propagande anti
vaccinales c'est comme les sites
complotistes et c'est comme toutes
sortes de gens qui racontent des bobards
mais qui finissent par les raconter
tellement tellement pseudo convaincante
qui trouve des gens pour les croire
c'est évidemment extrêmement regrettable
maintenant quand un vaccin existera pour
de vrai je ne sais que la pédagogie des
uns et des autres vous les médias y
compris aura été bien faite et de
manière transparente
peut-être est-ce qu'on verra plus de
gens se faire vacciner l'afub la
vaccination obligatoire n'étant
évidemment pas la solution vers laquelle
on semble se diriger
merci beaucoup six médecins hospitaliers
professeur d'économie de la santé
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france